sont les services de gériatr
le CIUSSS de l'Ouest-de-l'Île,
Davide Gentile a suivi l'une de
leurs éqleurs équipes.
Le ministre Christian Dubé a
- OK. On va aller voir
M. Janvier, voir comment ça va.
- C'est une équipe qui travaille
à préserver la dignité d'a
Dre NATHALIE ZAN, gériatrie
hospital., Maisonneuve-Rosemont
- On vient voir une personne
âgée de 89 ans qui a un trouble
neurocognitif majeur.
- Ils accompagnent
- M. Janvier?
- En ce jeudi matin,
on rencontre M. Janvier, qui ne
sort plus de sa petite chambre.
Il mange
collectionne les couverts,
qui remplissent toutes
- Comme ça, vous allez avoir
de la place.
les armoires avec l'infirmier
Robin Boulianne. Une façon
un prétexte pour l'osculter.
- C'est vrai que ça change pas.
qu'il est en perte d'autonomie
et qu'il n'est plus capable de
clairement, veut rester,
parce qu'il réalise pas
- Le vieil homme suggère
de se raser aux ciseaux.
- Ah, non, ça, c'est pas bon.
- Clairement, la résidence
pour personnes âgées n'est plus
un environnement assez
On tente de l'accompagner
doucement vers la suite.
- On réussit à le maintenir icin
veut, c'est de réussir à le
relocaliser ailleurs où ils vont
mieux répondre à ses besoins,s e
retrouve à l'urgence.
- Chaque visite est un geste
de plus pour tenter d'éviter
- Lui acheter un Philips.
- Un rasoir électrique? Oui.
- Prochain stop : chez uneire qi
de problèmes cognitifs.
ROBIN BOULIANNE, infirmer,
Centre multiservice gériatri- Jx
semaines, elle ava
conjonctivite, elle avait l'oeil
purulent, elle se les murs pour.
- Locataire dans us-
sol, elle semble de moins en
- Est-ce que les
étourdissements, c'est plus
ou moins qu'avant?
- C'est moins qu'avant.
- Elle a chuté et s'est blessée
il y a quelques semaines.
là? Ça, c'est la vieille
blessure, là.
- Ici aussi, on soigne en
attendant un hébergement plus
pour personnes âgées semi-
autonomes.
- Stabiliser la patiente puis
réhabilisation avec elle
en attendant de trouver une
relocali
à ses besoins.
- Robin et la Dre Zan
travaillent en collaboration
le même objectif: éviter des
nuisibles à l'hôpital.
- La personne va attendre un
c'est ça qu'on ne veut plus
faire. Oengorger lengorger lengs
hôpitaux pôur que les hôpitaux
puissent donner des soins
- Pour l'instant, la gériatrieàn
plutôt que la norme. Mais c'est
le gouvernement veut multipl
pour éviter que les hôpitaux
Ici Davide Gentile,
Radio-Canada, Mon